herzlich kommt eine neue folge ich fahre
leute wir sind heute in düsseldorf und
fahren eine absolute sportwagen legende
ich gebe euch nur drei buchstaben f
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und er besitzt von diesem wunderschönen
sls henry es geht die grösste ich leute
den keller unter euch ist als er 197
bekannt wirklich ein sportwagen ein noch
moderner sportwagen der auf dem besten
weg ist eine legende zu werden 571 ps
aus dem v8 sauger 6,20 8 liter hubraum
56 newtonmeter drehmoment und einfach
eine kranke bucht kommt mir anschaue
wissen rum habe kann ich mal von drüben
schauen viele viele sagen ja hier weil
es ja auch daran steht 6,3 liter aber
das ist cap das ist die der alte cap von
amg bmw 204 das ist ein 6,20 8 oder 6,2
liter hubraum motor und es ist einfach
lass das mal auf euch wirken leute was
eine wucht vor 1920 zeug richtig
schmiedefelgen sehr geil leute also
normalerweise werden vergossen das ist
ein schmiedefelgen sind nochmal können
auch antiken leichter konstruiert werden
richtig richtig richtig geil guck mal
auf der spoiler dahinten lustigerweise
einen teil von diesem auto bin ich quasi
schon gefahren jetzt ist er noch
besoffen von gestern nein bin ich nicht
es geht um das getriebe und zwar ist der
truck getriebe drin die basis zumindest
das ist auch ein ferrari 458 den bin ich
schon gefahren auf einem kanal und ja
aber das ist wirklich gratis auch
direkte konkurrenten ja ja richtig
richtig krass das ist der roadster leute
deswegen hat er keine flügeltüren
normalerweise hat aber es fällt schon
mal gesehen hat er die gal wings wieder
300 sl damals und das ist einfach das
ist so geil diese diese hommage an
diesen alten sportwagen das ist einfach
richtig sexy und leute an der stelle ein
kleiner hinweis mehr hat ein vöglein
geflüstert dass vielleicht auch
irgendwann mal 300 sl auf diesem youtube
kanal kommt
habe ich nur gehört weiß ja nicht der
sls wurde von 2010 bis 2014 gebaut ist
das erste von amg selbst entwickelte
fahrzeug und können wir unter die
motorhaube schauen dann sehen wir
nämlich gleich was ganz interessantes
leute ja hier und zwar erst guckt euch
bei uns diese motorhauben und jetzt mein
mann kann man sie bisher und dann kann
man die noch höher machen
wenn wir auf der tanke richtig den
dicken machen will
leute schaut mal hier das hier ist die
vorderachse und der motor beginnt hier
deswegen nennt man das hier
frontmittelmotor also erst noch front
vor den passagieren aber quasi schon so
einem mittelmotor anlehnung weil hinter
der vorderachse richtig geil und ist
noch ein sauger leute kein turbolader
6,2 liter hubraum und du hast eben schon
mal kurz an gemacht zum rangieren er
klingt auf jeden fall richtig krass was
kann man auch dazusagen heute trans axle
bauweise also motor ist vorne das
getriebe ist hinten hinter den
passagieren das 14 sportwagen tauglichen
gewichtsverteilung von ich glaub 750 43
hat er manche dinge einfach eine wucht
was das für die luft heran hat ist davon
nicht allzu kleine bruder
er hat sich einfach eine windkraftanlage
in deine montag vielleicht habt ihr auch
schon gesehen an bild ich habe richtig
tief in die tasche gegriffen haben wir
diese videos noch geiler machen können
leute 6000 euro und kameras etappen
investiert und ich hoffe es gefällt euch
keller das auspuffrohr ist quasi so frei
stehen also ja aber das hat auch sogar
ein grund okay weil
manche fans beim c63 mit dem 6,2 liter
damals die auspuffanlage die dehnt sich
oder zieht sich so sehr zusammen während
der fahrt dass die sich hier gedacht
haben okay wir machen im prinzip blenden
ja okay das schon echt ein extremer
unterschied war mein vater früher auch
den c63 mit dem 6 0 2 als kombi da bin
ich mal vorbei gelaufen hat mir das mein
haus meine meinen beiden gefragt am
auspuff verbrennen weil da sind so weit
raus steht tatsächlich kraft der ja das
ist wirklich einfach legende leute das
ist mittlerweile eigentlich auch moderne
deutsche automobilgeschichte sexy ist
einfach sexy was nicht sexy ist nach
aktuellen technischen stand ist das
interieur aber gut der wagen ist voll in
ordnung 212 ja ja ja aber gute man muss
sagen handwerklich ist es natürlich geil
hast hier schaltwippen ich hätte
erwartet dass der carbon am ende ein
bisschen carbon am lenker das aber so es
gab ein carbon paket ja aber das hat er
jetzt nicht die sitze sehen aber krass
auch sehr sehr krass komfortabel also
wie gesagt das auto ist an sich total
komfortabel soll ja auch richtung gt
gehen ja aber es ist halt eigentlich
nicht so viel großen wünschen wir uns
jetzt vielleicht gemacht okay das heißt
wir quälen uns das gleiche für euch
quälen nicht aber ja geil übrigens leute
die farbe die ihr seht ist leon rot und
degas ist es so krass an dem tag wo
dieses video online kommt ist einfach
gerade 20 stunden rennen immer was ein
timing das ist dieses wochenende was ein
timing leute heute kommt alles zusammen
übrigens leon rot eine sehr beliebte die
beliebteste eigentlich beim sls oder
albin wurde er vorgestellt wurde ja aber
die farbe kostet 213 müller was
ach so ach so dvd die die amg
sonderlackierung ich glaube meine ich
sogar die gab es fast nur auf dem sls
ich bin mir aber gar nicht sicher dass
lena roth eher eine sache noch nur damit
euch nicht wundert der wurde nicht
unvollständig ausgeliefert sondern die
abdeckung hier die ist gerade noch beim
sattler einzelner ja der wurde schon
vollständig ausgeliefert aber das hier
ist noch beim sattler weil sich ein
bisschen eingeklemmt hat bei einem dach
auf und zu machen ja perfekt also dann
wisst ihr bescheid warum hier die
abdeckung fehlt das hier diese wie soll
das denn diese finden da das ja gerade
auch an den 300 sl ja ja das stimmt
nicht die saga der angelehnt ist
das geil alter im prinzip auch der
direkte nachfolger ein ja jahre später
also circa
hat ein bisschen gedauert mercedes ist
nächsten vielleicht wissen schneller
eine ganz wichtige sache dürfe natürlich
nicht vergessen heute bei so einem
hubraum starken fahrzeug und das ist der
sound check deswegen henry wenn du so
nett wär's jetzt kannst du einmal
anschmeißen
düsseldorfer hafen
möwen fliegen noch rum für mich wie in
der nordsee und jetzt liegt
tiger ist
das laut
alter hasst ole grobe idee mit wie viel
der eingetragen ist kommen wir gleich
das ist doch krank
also das ist will ich eine ganz andere
lautstärke erstmal die von modernen also
man kann sich schon denken aber das ist
krank leute wirklich ja wo er im
fahrzeugschein reinschauen tipp an alle
leute die auf der kö pension geht ich
das fahrgeräusch 74 fahrgeräusch
muss das waren die das war aber also das
war auf jeden fall das geräusch ist 92
2015 geben hier oben ist also das war
krank laut aber leute fahrgeräusch ist
jetzt das richtige stichwort denn ich
würde sagen jetzt gehen wir mal dran du
fährst kurzen runde und dann wechseln
werde ja ich bin richtig heiß und damit
sitzen wir im auto leute es
ganz wichtig noch vorneweg leute dass
das ist mir auch gerade beim ok fahrwerk
john bock hat das ist vor allem sagen
sie mir ganz wichtig vorneweg leute
gerade wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen
teurer autos geht seit auf jeden fall
nett und lieb zu den gästen ja also die
kombis format und zeigen ihre autos
bieten die quasi an so dass wir die alle
genießen können deswegen seit die zu
denen tut mir den gefallen und
damit der zuerst eine frage was bedeutet
autos für dich
was bedeuten autos für mich also ich sag
mal ich habe das in die wiege gelegt
bekommen eine art und weise mein vater
war schon immer sehr auto enthusiastisch
und für mich bedeutet das auch so ein
stückchen freiheit weil abends wenn ich
mal bock griechen runde und dann einfach
darauf weiß ich nicht kann damit alles
machen und ich kenne mitreisen ich kann
damit spaß haben
ist alltag und freizeit irgendwie
zugleich also für mich berechtigt die
ganze menge muss ich sagen leitet meine
freunde auch sehr darunter
und ja sag mal warum sl es gibt ja viele
andere sportwagen auf jeden fall aber
ich sag mal so ist es halt ein schönes
auto meiner meinung nach ist natürlich
immer meinungs- sache aber das ding das
ganze fahren und du hast auch auf der
anderen seite keinen wertverlust
chatroom und
ja ich fand den damals also raus kamen
so 10 fand ich das schon echt ein
wunderschönes auto ich kann mich noch
ganz genau daran erinnern autobild dem
rother kuppe war da drin und das war
einfach alles
als zehnjähriger damals 16
einfach unfassbar und
so ist das dann irgendwie gekommen
ich habe lange nach ihm gesucht aber ich
muss sagen mir ging es gar nicht so um
die farbe sondern mehr hier um zum
beispiel mann also was kann ich
eigentlich primär wichtiger als ein auto
kann es immer verlieren oder soja
schauen wir auch am anfang nicht sicher
oder wir fragen uns immer die farbe und
jetzt
aber als er dann live da war war es auch
gut gefallen und
unternehmen
noch so
[Musik]
eine sache habe ich ganz vergessen war
an bord leute und zwar nochmal
besonderheit der vom svs der hat eine
trockensumpfschmierung
das bedeutet dass man quasi eine viel
kleinere wandel unter dem motor darunter
hat was ist mit meiner leistung hast du
so ein fettes becken und trocken so
fasst eine kleinere wander und externe
behälter noch und letzten endes warum
ist das relevant einfach weil man dem
den motor dann tiefer platzieren kann
weil ich so hoch ist so und ja also ja
keine kosten gescheut schmiedefelgen
trockensumpfschmierung trans axle für
den sportwagen flair
egal was alter was sind das für den
schiffs das schon ganz gut an das ja
krank übrigens noch ein vögelchen das
ist glaube ich mit dem filmischen was
den etwa oder das lg zweckverband hat
mir geht's weiter dass eventuell auf 1
812 super fast zweimal kommt auf dem
giller sauger wir haben jetzt nur damit
so ein problem das muss ich den
berichten leider der der akku vor
unserer kamera ist heute ein bisschen
schwächer das bedeutet dass wenn es für
dich okay ist sich vielleicht auch jetzt
schon mal etwas anderes steuer gehen
würde ja leute hier kommt der
henninger-turm gespielt hat ist der
vater startknopf
esp off auch wichtig die dämpfe
einstellen und das ist der am knopf wird
machte der können dir das hier anzeigen
oder eben auch nicht hier kannst du auf
alles mögliche stellen okay
heime temperatur natürlich
und dann wieviel war die reifen haben
und da kannst du noch ganz viele
rennstrecken die anschauen und dann die
zeit nehmen wie schnell sie zum beispiel
auf dem nürburgring war es auf dem
hockenheimring bz wenn man ja auch alles
nachschauen wenn man in le mans in road
unterwegs ist dann ist das schon richtig
richtig übrigens hier der der fahrmodus
war lebe hier der ist der neuere es gibt
noch einen weiteren der der iss herzlich
man genau also ich finde persönliche
sieht das ist jetzt nicht böse gesagt
oder so da sieht ein bisschen aus dem
krückstock hey hier aber naja vielleicht
irgendein bild einblenden oder so
den finde ich schon deutlich schöner
muss ich sagen und daran erkennt man
auch das ist ein neueres modell ist weil
die ersten jahren halt eben diesen
komisch aus denn nicht so schön aussehen
und sagte ja
22 waren
ist das ein schuljunge aber man sich
fühle mich sehr wohl
komfortabel in den sitzen also es ist
man würde festgehalten sondern definitiv
also ich finde es ist auch das ist ja
mehr in richtung gt fahrzeuge also grand
tourer ein paar strecken mit ein
bisschen gepäck oder soja ich finde es
vom fahrkomfort definitiv mehr als in
ordnung ja für so ein sportliches
fahrzeug safe wobei der auch sehr sehr
hart das muss man sagen aber trotzdem
gern irgendwo
einmal einmal zur höffner leute mit dem
sls passen sowohl gegen rot-rot
sls weißt du was er steht ja sport
leicht super richtig genau und der sl
steht die bezirksstelle nicht für sport
leicht und der slr damals also dass
dieses das legendäre uhlenhaut coupé
dass er geblieben
superleicht rennsport oder die abkürzung
deswegen wäre doch eigentlich
superleicht sport passend für den sls
warum man sportler ist super das klingt
ganz komisch aber ich glaube diese so
ihre linie treu geblieben erstmal
ist dann für hannover
dieser motor vorne dran seid echt ein
paar meter gefühlvoll die herren ja
so jetzt bloß nicht
spricht sich rum davon so ich weiß gar
nicht wer wird schon gehen da passt
wir sind jetzt wir sind weder zu
übersehen noch zu überhören
hahaha geil hat ja die haben doch den
eigenen format her ich wollte linken
blinker 20
reiter
locker geworden ist das geil digger ist
das geil
ist amazon ein
wir können leider und jetzt ist
stammkunde
dialekt
aber wenn es dann losgeht dann können
wir einmal lässt sie ein bisschen platz
und die drei ja genau
man muss ja auch mal sicherheitsabstand
zum vordermann die können auch mal einen
drauf ich her
jakarta
ist das kranker ach du scheiße da ist er
komplett feierabend soundtechnisch ist
ja schon ganz
wenig twitter auch nicht dritter nummero
duo wollen wir
[Applaus]
ja
er kommt immer noch einer hinterher
weiß ich jetzt auch der tank tank sagt
du hast ja wissen auf den letzten zehn
letzten zehntel er ist ein zehntel oder
ja na schauen wir mal mit dem mit dem
pfeil ein bisschen runter bis er sagt ja
kilometer noch hat ab start 20 kann man
nix mit
50 jahren gerecht
hat gott die welt
gleich kommt von schildern und wir alle
kennen und lieben was wir alle kennen
und lieben und schätzen
woher
ich habe hier sogar
einmal latschen
[Musik]
geil
dieses runter
[Musik]
dann langsam wieder zurück in düsseldorf
richtig ich glaube wir haben eigentlich
fast alles gesehen und gesprochen oder
ich denke ja dann würde ich sagen henry
vielen vielen dank fürs dabeisein serie
faust drauf und das kamera halten leute
und wir aber bei eine sache nun ja
vielleicht kommt es ja in zwei monaten
noch mal wieder ja genau vielleicht
komme ich in zwei monaten noch einmal
wieder vielleicht wird's dann
amerikanisch man weiß nicht was kann das
sein könnte sein leute auf jeden fall
jetzt ab in die bewertung und die
bewertung geht wieder mit dem aussehen
der sls ist definitiv ein schönes auto
das muss man auf jeden fall sagen aber
zumindest in der roadster variante finde
ich ihnen nicht außergewöhnlich und
überragend schön wie es andere autos
schon mal in diesem format auch wenn ich
den wagen unfassbar greifen da kann ich
ja nicht nur zehn punkten geben acht von
zehn dementsprechend die beschleunigung
ist richtig stark der sls roadster wurde
von verschiedenen zeitschriften zwischen
3,6 und 3,8 sekunden von 0 auf 100 1
gemessen das ist sehr sehr schnell unter
vier sekunden und reicht für eine acht
von zehn ebenfalls der punktgewinn ist
dass ich gar nicht so der wagen kommt
der wagen ist jetzt schon die moderne
legende und ist eine hommage an einen
der legendärsten deutschen sportwagen
den 300 sl und dementsprechend muss ist
hier ohne wenn und aber zehn von zehn
punkten geben insgesamt kommen damit der
spaß wertung auf 26 von 30 punkten und
auf einen geteilten vierten platz
genauso cool wie der wagen ist es
allerdings auch unpraktisch wie man sich
schon vielleicht gedacht hatte herz
waren und recht ordentlichen kofferraum
aber nur zwei sitze ziemlich ziemlich
hohen verbrauch aber ich glaube das
können wir nach zehn leute trotzdem
müssen wir natürlich transparenten fair
sein und vier von zehn punkten geben das
preis leistungs verhältnis ist absolut
bombastisch bei diesem auto wenn euch
jetzt bist du verrückt geworden hört zu
der wagen ist zwar kaum für unter
200.000 euro zu haben also der rot rot
aber das auto gewinnt einfach an wert
das liegt an wert tagtäglich zu das ist
absolut banane weil mittlerweile einfach
sehr viele auto das hätte leute diesen
wagen schätzen und kennen und wissen was
er bedeutet und dementsprechend die
nachfrage sehr groß dass neun von zehn
schließlich der komfort ist natürlich
nicht die große stärke des sls er ist
zwar gta konzipiert also in gran turismo
dass man damit aber ein bisschen länger
fahren kann der ist auch nicht bretthart
oder unbequem man merkt aber schon die
unebenheiten der straße sehr gut vier
von zehn damit seine allerdings
förderung sehr stark und gerade für den
zehn jahre alten sportwagen sehr starke
17 von 30 punkten und einen platz neun
insgesamt lag damit bei 43 von 60
punkten und einem platz fünf in der
gesamtwertung aber ich muss wirklich
sagen dieses auto ist so unfassbar geil
ich habe mit ihm darüber geredet er
meinte was würdest du neben 450 italia
oder den sls gar keine frage sls hammer
hammer hammer auto kann man ganz ganz
schwer hier in den punkten ausdrücken
aber glaubt es mir das ding ist einfach
wahnsinn und ich habe mich verliebt
schreibe gerne eure meinung zum sls
unterbewertungen die kommentare reichen
leute und bis zum nächsten sonntag es
wird legendär nächste woche das kann ich
jetzt schon versprechen als gut